[Music]
few animals inspire more fear than
sharks but out of the millions of people
worldwide who swim in the ocean each
year less than a hundred are attacked of
the more than 300 species of shark only
a small number are proven man-eaters the
most dangerous are tiger sharks bull
sharks and great whites a bite from them
can literally cost life and limb sharks
may bite people out of hunger but often
as not will bite out of simple curiosity
they'll gladly sample anything unusual
bobbing in the water like a person just
to see what it tastes like so knowing
how to respond and mean the difference
between life and
if a shark attacks should you splash
violently go for the odds or play dead
the correct answer is B go for the odds
splashing violently only attracts more
sharks toward you playing dead leads to
being dead a limp body tells the shark
it's time to tuck in for a big meal your
best chance is to strike at its soft
spots its eyes gills and nose make the
shark decide you're not worth the
trouble and while it's deciding get to
shore as fast as you can
and that's how you survive a shark
attack